what who are you looking at she takes me
upstairs to her bedroom where we have
relations and I'm Billy hey hey I'm John
and I'm Melissa and today we're playing
a game of never have I ever never have I
ever got kicked out removed from an
event I maybe I get invited back I had a
little boy who was an extra steal one of
my props during an actual shoot and I
went and got one of the crew members and
the little boy lied and they believed
him and they kicked me out and then five
minutes later came outside and
apologized followed him because someone
had thought maybe we should look at the
tape and see if the clowny who'd been
doing it for 45 years was telling the
truth or not
screw you a little boy Oh somebody's
Lincoln origami King oh yeah
never have I ever used a pick-up line
try to get a date in clown me there was
a portion of time when I was on tour and
I was going around the country and I had
like inappropriate ops on my phone which
I'm not proud of but I met somebody and
we were at the show and I still had my
makeup on and there was that moment
where I was like I have
but were you like hey how about you help
me take it off we kissed
drinkin I was at a kid party and I kind
of forgot that I was like and like
there's this guy at the party who was
cute and I was like flirting with him
and then I was like it's hip dad like he
looks like what am i doing I can't this
is wrong he might have a wife but I gave
him my Instagram he never followed me
never have I ever bombed out of
children's party
the birthday boy came up to me and asked
me to make a balloon animal and I said
you forgot to say the magic words and he
looked at me and said my dad is paying
you do what I want and I then proceeded
to do a magic show with my clown act and
did not get one single laughs thank you
than spoiled bel-air boy you're now 20
and your parents paid for you to go to
college to get you into college you are
me you know who you are
bel-air get out don't look at me like
that
what who are you looking at never have I
ever rode in a clown car I have to me
yep circus guy over here eleven and a
half people were inside my clown car
it's like magic or their little
compartments that magic it are you guys
just like real close in to cuddle
telling the secret never have I ever
faked a clown skill at a party oh please
I have not I have not that's right alive
because they're like hey girl juggle if
you like
they wanted like a really good balloon
animal artist it was rough and I mean
the kids like here's the thing about it
the kid everybody knew they could all
tell cuz they were asking for really
specific things and I just kept making a
short or a hat for a dog yeah and they
were like um this is not like the kids
are starting to get like suspicious you
know and then but I tried to like make
it a part of like Who I am I was like
ooh see you did I don't make what you
wanted next question never have I ever
had to cut corners on makeup because I
was running late definitely have oh it
is never cute I'm always running late
and I know it's bad and if my boss
sometimes knew what I looked like she
would probably fire me for time
management
yeah just basically messing around or
Gavin the whole time when I'm supposed
to be doing my makeup it happens on a
social queen
I was hired as a balloon artist so I
wasn't on camera and then after we were
done they came to me and they said we
told you to bring you a clown outfit
right I go yeah I think it was there any
chance you can be a clown in ten minutes
and here's how I did my makeup clown
white eye all mouth red lipstick cheek
cheek I'm ready
never have I ever wore my costume when I
wasn't working I have I have to it's fun
you ought to pay me to put this outfit
on in this
who doesn't like a little attention but
the sad thing is like walking around LA
looking like this I'll be honest not a
lot of heads are turning people are just
like yeah it's another Tuesday for
Alyssa look I love eating cotton candy
and popcorn and just sometimes I gotta
make sure that the costume still fits
there's got to be a line help I'm a
prisoner in a Chinese cookie never have
I ever drop something while juggling
that's why I don't juggle sitting here
yeah I have I've never been good at
playing any sports can't catch a ball to
save my life
it's mathletics only thing I can catch
is a cold I'm juggling scarves on a TV
show and I drop one scarf while I'm
juggling and doing tricks one scarf and
the cameraman who doesn't speak English
great says he's dropping his rags rags
silk gorgeous expensive rags Thank You
mr. Swedish man who ruined my day never
have I ever scared a kid on purpose I
like don't be it was my nieces and
nephews I thought that I would be very
funny by being a little bit scary
typically I try to be the opposite of
scary and be very approachable but my
nieces and nephews
does anyone remember the story of the
little boy who stole the clown's prop
when I was later walking to the bathroom
and saw the boy crying I may have looked
at him and done this and it may have
made him cry just a little bit more
sorry bad boy never have I ever been
inappropriate in my clown makeup okay I
imagine you want a story right all right
white wine and I like balloon pump quick
show of hands who went viral having sex
with Julia Louie Dreyfus worldwide only
me what did you say I don't have proof
really because here I am being picked up
in clown disco by Julia Louie Dreyfus
she takes me upstairs to her bedroom
where we have relations this would be
the picture you see if you google Julia
Louie Dreyfus clown sex that's me and
what do I do is any gentleman clown I
leave her and on the last page of the
magazine we have a baby now I know what
you're saying what happened afterwards
well I'll tell you two months later
completely by coincidence
my nephew was playing basketball with
Julia Louie Dreyfus his son she
introduces me to her husband and I said
to him I hope you can forgive but I have
been undressed as a clown making love to
your wife and I've been photographed and
he said who hasn't I am NOT she couldn't
have been lovelier I blamed Stephen King
for that question I mean not as a clown
but as a kid it was like super cool to
go down to the sewers and
look for ninja turtles and stuff so I
hung out in sewers helped to be a little
bit more specific with your question all
right I bet this one starts with never
have I ever
oh my never have I ever been judged for
being a clown no do not get me started
don't get me started
try dating and having to tell people
what you do for a living and then get
back to me okay because what I do in
that situation is I become a clown
ghosted that's right
everybody watching this video right now
Brown I feel like we need to reclaim the
word clown I feel like people think it's
spooky scary which it is in popular
culture it is like I don't know how to
explain it but it is just like I think
people are kind of condescending to me a
lot of the times when I'm like in this
look and like at parties to with like
the adults who are like also at the
parties they're like oh you're a clown
huh okay like I used to make a little
balloon animal you know it's like this
is this is a beautiful job that is a
helping children smile making the world
a better place
oh my gosh pulling out the big guns and
wanting to know what color underwear I
have on and that's what we learn today
on heaven or have enough on
[Music]